- I remember hearing about Greg
at ABCD Camp.
You know, people were comparing him to Bill Russell.
I mean,
you don't get compared to Bill Russell when you're 17 years old.
- [Announcer]: Here's Oden backing in, doubled but he dunks.
- Oden's having an outstanding ballgame.
- We had our schools that we both liked.
He liked Michigan State, I liked North Carolina.
Our last visit that we took was together at Ohio State.
We sat there in the arena talking to Thad Matta and
kinda looked at each other and was like,
"Uh, are we gonna do this?"
- Me and Mike decided to come to the Ohio State University.
- "You want to go to Ohio State?"
He's like, "If it's cool with you."
You know, that's just how he is.
- This was a place that we both
felt comfortable being at,
a place where we know we can grow as young men.
I wanted, you know, to bring a national championship here.
- [Announcer]: Basket by Oden.
- Our expectations going into the tournament,
we felt like we were a championship-caliber team.
- [Announcer]: Ten seconds to go and a foul.
Cage will go to the line.
Oden picks up his fifth foul.
The NCAA tournament, Xavier,
I was sitting on the bench like, "I'm about to have
a spring break for the first time in my life.
- [Announcer]: Conley, five to go.
Lewis has been awesome. Lets it go...
brings it home!
He ties it at 62!
- And then the overtime came and Mike Conley,
I think he got seven points to start the overtime.
Me and him was watching the film after
in the hotel, and just looking at him smile and
actually seeing all that, that work and that emotion he put out there.
- We were giddy kids at the time, just enjoying it.
And being able to watch the film, it was just like,
"Yeah, that really happened. Man, I can't believe that happpened."
It felt like we couldn't lose after that.
- We definitely knew how good Tennessee was.
- [Announcer]: Rebound, Tennessee.
- Big rebound.
- I mostly remember my blocked shot at the end of the game.
Ron Lew, like, screamed in my face afterwards.
When I blocked that shot, my chin had hit the ground,
and when it had hit the ground, it, like, cracked so many of my teeth
and exposed so many of my cavities.
We won the game, but I was like,
yeah, I was at the dentist for the next five weeks.
- [Announcer]: Ohio State wins it 92-76.
- His presence offensively, defensively,
he changes the whole dynamic of a whole team.
We were so used to having him there as an anchor.
- [Announcer]: The Buckeyes buy a ticket to Monday night's finals.
Ohio State and Florida for the national championship.
- That national championship game, you know,
we're all nervous sitting in the locker room,
and we're like, "What's Coach Matta gonna say to get us riled up?"
And then he walks in, he turns off the light, and
he puts on this clip from
"Wedding Crashers."
- Damn you.
I almost nunchucked you, you don't even realize!
- Ouch.
- "I almost nunchucked you!"
That's what we watched before the national championship game.
And then the game started, and I think
our sense of urgency kinda kicked in a little bit too late.
- We threw a lot of bodies at 'em.
The strength of our team was that we just could
keep throwing bigs at 'em,
and good ones too.
- Joakim Noah, Al Horford, those are the guys that
I had to go up against.
So yeah, I definitely got tired. Like, they definitely wore me out.
That team was a great team. You know, two national championships.
But you need to tell the Florida fans that doing the Gator Chomp
to an 18-year-old kid after he just
lost the national championship is—
I almost cried walking off that court right there.
- You know what? I would've probably been crying too.
I'm happy we won, though.
- I loved it here in Columbus, Ohio. But when the opportunity
comes to be the No. 1 draft pick,
I think you gotta take that.
- With the first pick in the 2007 NBA draft,
the Portland Trail Blazers select Greg Oden
from Ohio State University.
- [Announcer]: Scola gives Brooks the pick.
Uh-oh.
Oh, Greg.
Greg went down and—
Oh, his knee is—
Holy cow, Portland doesn't need this.
- When I was an NBA player for those six years,
I was rarely on the floor, just with all those injuries I've had,
I didn't feel like I did enough.
I physically could not do it.
It was like if I gave one good day of that hard work,
the next three days I spent rehabbing, just
trying to get my knees to feel good for me to
sit down or walk down the stairs.
It was so much pain I was going through
just to try to get myself to the level I wanted to be at.
- I think bust is a tough term because his was
injury-driven, not skill-driven.
We all saw what he can do. His athleticism,
his ability, there's no bust about that.
- People call whatever they want a bust.
In the context, compared to some, I can see it that way too.
And then some people get mad at me for saying that.
It's like, "Don't talk that way about yourself,"
and I'm like, "Oh, OK."
But, you know, it's just a word.
When I was deciding if I was going to be done playing basketball,
it was definitely a mental switch I had to make.
A lot of watching old YouTube clips and, you know, crying by myself.
I picked up the phone and called Coach Matta.
It was actually the greatest thing I did.
He was just like, "Come be around the program. Come be around
the guys. Stay around basketball. Stay around, you know,
just basketball minds." You know, keeping that open
to give me a reason to wake up and just go to the gym.
You know, to see people.
- When big fella told me he was going back to school to
be a coach, get his degree,
I was happy. I was proud of him.
- So, when I graduate, I want my spot to be right here.
I'm gonna graduate and finish my undergrad in May.
Don't second-guess.
He ain't blocking you straight up.
I want to go into coaching next.
I really enjoy trying to figure out this new game of basketball.
- He's got so much to teach, so much
to, you know, give to these guys.
I hope they enjoy having me here.
I hope I'm telling them things that's gonna impact their lives
on and off the court.
And I hope they enjoy it as much as I do.